[Applaudissements]
victor cibona l'espoir indigo victoire
parce que c'est mauvais temps à
retrouver en replay tu avais très envie
qu'ils sont pas du tout d'abord allé
battre c'est long 25 minutes est mon cas
vite combal touchante à damas merci
beaucoup à mon chéri si tu aimes bien
les 24 heures tv tape dans tes mains
si tu as vu aller 24 ans tv qui commence
ma chronique table en tma jpeg via les
24 heures vélo il ya tout ce qu'il
fallait pas manquer les dates de 24
heures par heures tape dans tes mains
c'est parti ça m'arrive de regarder à
22h hier l'équipe olympique suisse nous
a encore bluffé
après nous avons appris comment utiliser
un escalator bondé voici comment
s'entraîner au bobsleigh quand il n'a
pas neigé
[Musique]
à 20h on s'est sérieusement demandé si
gilles bouleau n'avait pas déjeuné avec
de jean pierre pernaut parce qu'on peut
croire qu'il a pris un petit bijou lui
aussi dans les pays développés le député
et mathématicien cédric villani et le
bronze dans l'épreuve du combiné
sylvain me l'envoie sander en d1 des
adrets et vincent py à 15 heures pour
rien au monde on aurait raté le shooting
photo de l'actrice mannequin kate upton
et commenté en délire elle est prête
pour jouer profil bas monde est rien
oui
non
à 19h estelle denis nous a parlé de
paris sportifs sur l'équipe et je ne
sais pas quoi penser aujourd'hui estelle
mais vu la bonne idée la télé du cinéma
de l'humour ou encore de la cuisine de
nous donner leur pronostic pour ce match
aller voir que certains perçoivent ont
fait des choix étonnants voici tout de
suite les stars du porno de leicester ça
vient de tomber on a trouvé les pires
cambrioleurs au monde cherchait plus des
génies pareil on trouvera pas mûres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle vous connaissez phrases et
j'adore ces notions le connard qui
souffrent on va l'applaudir
allez allez allez can be
[Applaudissements]
pour simone ali bonne ambiance est pas
gâté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
papa tu me l'as lattes et quand même
[Applaudissements]
généralement dieu merci beaucoup merci
levine et quoi j'ai maté les jo
fournissant des deux minutes là on n'a
pas donc on peut bosser là le nom de
remettre c'est une boucle d'oreille un
collier
[Applaudissements]
ces boucles d'oreilles de babar entre
deux cours de salsa
j'ai ma télé les jo brut ont frôlé uche
voilà je suis comme ça alors les jo
d'hiver il faut savoir que c'est un
événement planétaire et plusieurs stars
se sont déplacés incognito sur place
pour pouvoir être présent regarder on a
vu un philippe etchebest qui jugeraient
épreuve telle entre rottiers et la césar
pour l'a4 dans sébastien chabal était là
aussi la même chose et une médaille
parce que le son aux savanes tout le
rallye comme respect de l'adversaire on
apprend bien jean michel apathie s'est
reconverti en coach va lui aussi et
matthieu delormeau était absent hier
pour encourager le style et le bowling
la faune de ce qui est beau lipsky
éboulis
c'est donc très bourgeoise elle ce matin
c'était les épreuves de luge et quand tu
les regardes tu as l'impression d'être
en train de faire le king master dans
une fête foraine
[Applaudissements]
bonjour voisin fédération
[Musique]
regardez c'est mon moment préféré c'est
cet entraîneur français qui donnait une
interview en direct il enviait
débrancher son talkie walkie
problème son pote elle même humour que
jean mis un but pour la france puis
aussi pour tout groupe qui est ici qui
va dans ce sens paul avec j'espère la
descente dans de bonnes conditions
[Applaudissements]
le moustique
[Rires]
j'ai en fait j'ai eu une chute ans rien
que des pages et l'habitude et de gens
et ça me lancer dans veut dire quoi que
vous êtes prêts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez tous regarder psg real moi
j'ai regardé le curling parce que c'est
là que ça se passe d'ailleurs et pendant
pg rennes on s'est envoyé beaucoup de
ceux qui sont à caractère au secret
turing
j'ai eu plein de choses déjà c'est
tellement un sport va annoncer en plus
en plus en sûre le curry même les
commentateurs maintenant ils font des
vannes sur le sport qui sont parties
commentées en corée
80 85 kg bon balayeur mais propre chez
eux
alors pourquoi c'est toujours en couple
le curling et je sais pas si il a créé
autant sur son mari au badminton mais là
je peux vous dire que le gars fait pas
le malin je te vois dans la glace
tellement il bat l'effort les
britanniques qui mène 5 4
les britanniques comme cameron diaz qui
joue qui l'a pris et donc regarder c'est
cette jeune fille c'est une russe a
élaboré et d'hervé sur shanghai en oui c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est apparemment un chanteur très connu
et dans l'équipe canadienne de curling
et il avait des fans à se poser le
canadien c'est au dessus
voilà tout doucement
eurofer hall bachelor oui il bat le
bachot du peuple tunisien alors c'est
une jeune chanteuse léa pas si d'accord
hier à vinyan c'est pas mon lilian je me
tape outre délire ton nom c'est afida
turner c'est qu'ils adorent
[Musique]
après
au delà du golan et dans la chose à
faire j'ai un peu tôt
bon les jo d'hiver ça rime avec patrick
montel d'ailleurs ça rime pas du tout
devrais-je dire patrick mesner vu son
flair il connaît aussi les athlètes
parker on lui fera pas aujourd'hui hors
de question il les connaît tous par
coeur les afriques ça c'est
effectivement river était décroché un
petit pelouse
ses rangs alors derrière il serre les
dents
rayrolles tient toujours tribord alors
quand on part sur un nom russe n'a pas
tort il fait une vraie sortie de piste
en les faveurs du pronostic pour la
russie le van hamme et chasse-neige 1
échalote hachée ya pas d autres
journalistes nous ont régalé aussi déjà
gatti qui revient avec une seule
expression dans ses valises dans qu'il
l'a re sic depuis six jours vous ai dit
qu'il est parti pas pour amuser la
galerie les papiers pour acheter du
terrain tard j'ai beau aujourd'hui un
puits non plus hein il n'est pas venu
pour acheter du terrain la suite il
galère aussi à compter les norvégiens et
finit par oublier qu'il en direct c'est
un match je suis norvégien
quatre noms mais j'ai quatre rencontres
enfin j'ai préféré c'est céline géraud
elle a failli s'emmêler les pinceaux on
porte tous à la même chose s'est passé à
ça de ma mère pour les nuls
une petite question la longueur des skis
par rapport à la taille du sauteur
certains titres de fait gaffe quand même
certaines matières j'ai aussi matt et le
patinage artistique c'est bien ce sport
une passionne alors il faut leur délire
vous savez ils ont tous les tenues les
danses des trous et que personne ne leur
a dit que c'était plus de 1987 ils sont
dans leur dans leur bulle quoi regarder
c'est magnifique ce raid les corps et
les figures sont mal ici on a d'ailleurs
eu quelques moments de grâce ultime sur
le programme libre mais nelson monfort
et philippe candeloro commentaires n'en
reviennent pas regardez nous allons
prendre la direction du palais des
glaces de gangnam jay la suite de la
compétition par équipe
comme on a dans cette compétition
on a dit qu'on voit ça
aujourd'hui inversement ça c'est
excellent c'est
là
là que c'était beau mais le patinage ne
serez pas le patinage sans philippe
candeloro et ses blagues que personne ne
pense tout bas mais que lui dit où
l'artistique c'est lui ce qui ferait à
nous faire kiffer sous la bannière des
deux corées réunies à savoir guillaume
qui met alex quand chan kam chose est
sûre qu'ils sont que deux dans le groupe
de philippe candeloro en art trop sur la
culture asiatique et qui se rend compte
qu'il n'y connaît rien au milieu du
commentaire vous avez raison nelson
mais qui se transforment en rayon de
soleil à bord
au pays du soleil levant justement
oh [ __ ] opprimés
la région du globe
le soleil a parlé tous les matins
très bien en fait j'ai des génériques
chantés ce soir il faut que vous voyez
ça ouais il a une jambe a été tué quand
il chante ma mère inquiète pas bébé on
aide à ces tâches est si haut
alors j'ai un nouveau chouchou c'est par
un jeune joueur c'est un candidat de des
chiffres et des lettres il s'appelle
charneau il vos fringues c'est audacieux
mais il est adorable
regardez vous avez joué contre arnaud
qu'on accueille bonjour je connais pas
exactement
c'est bizarre il rappelle le candidat de
motus qui parlait super six vérités p au
p eut elle a hérité eux su retourner à
sacha même permis à ne sait bien lui
dont on se demandait mais ce que gilles
garneau a déjà participé à d'autres jeux
auparavant la réponse est oui
déjà en avril on l'a vu chez jean luc
lemoine noguès maillage avec sa jolie
frenchie championne sommes cernés en
pole man
en octobre 2015 on l'avait pas il est un
disciple sébastien folin en septembre
2014 des ajouts aux maillons faibles
avec juju courbet en ovins destans
étudiant en géographie
c'est parti trois corps avant faire les
2014 j'allais moi que je laime soja aux
questions pour un champion avec nous
dimanche dernier et non ça me va un
autre bouquin
c'est le
c'est fou quand même hein on l'a vu de
partout garneau il fait plus antenne que
cyril hanouna on l'avait vraiment
parcours président de la république et 7
ya sept ans étudiant en géographie le
travail qu'il abat camille c'est fou
j'ai moins de temps pour la danse mais
bon moi c'est non le sursis fait
retarder voulais voir autre chose voilà
excusez-moi afida on arrête de sonde de
ce massage mater jt il est bas afida et
isolement
mais je le garde populaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces motifs de mcafee da oui vous savez
tout messti peut-être des styles ça
dépend quel genre de mec qui sont
d'accord ces moyens sont des gentils
garçons 20 meilleurs ça me plaisait lui
c'est votre sim maxime à maxime oui à
les enfants à côté non mais il est très
bien elle est très très bien bah oui oui
oui très bien
basé mon cabinet saintrick 1 alors on
passe au bleu nuit des années j'ai tout
mater j'ai eu un choc
regardez déjà j'ai découvert qu'un truc
de fou il apprend sous le soir jean
pierre pernaut et chauffe a beau en vrai
way jean pierre pernaut il a décidé de
parler à crâne découvert dans grand
reportage sur tf1
très à l'écouté à faire même le
journaliste de bfm ce feuilleton en
parlant de nicolas hulot il ya trop
d'affaires
l'actualité judiciaire encore avec ces
deux informations ni culot d'abord cola
que ça ne se reproduise chez jean pierre
pernaut tu sens que les journalistes
sont plus jacques chirac ed sheeran à un
calage réseau pris la 6e place du
concours après le programme court c'est
une musique vie britannique est sharan
avant d'aller la prochaine enquête
sophie lapix doit annoncer la série
rizzoli and isles
elle prendra rct dans un instant la
météo d'anaïs bail de mire puis c'est le
retour de vos héroïnes rizzoli and isles
bonne soirée sur un rituel sacré
l'anglais sur france 2 il est en duplex
avec de grands champions français alexis
pinturault et victor muffat jeandet et
apparemment il avait un gros souci de
lumière alexis pinturault victor muffat
jeandet bonjour et bravo c'est c'est
quelque chose de formidable faut quand
même pas oublier que c'était un techo
énormément de bonheur enfin l équipe
avec les coaches derrière nous c'est ça
je pense que les prochaines heures voire
c'est quelque chose de formidable
fauconnet
[Applaudissements]
le super jolie de nos cités je vérifie
déjà des riches sont deux jeunes adorent
regarde ça victor cgt nous rejoignent
celles et les émissions par forfait et
que le générique est que la musique on
s'amuse à remettre les paroles si
vraiment ça devait expliquer ce qu'était
les émissions et ya deux nouveautés pmt
bien on t'aime
alors tu passeras demain demain et pas
demain parce que je suis un best-of qui
se piquerait canal ont l'argent on est
on les regarde parce qu'on n'a pas les
droits du coup
il ya toujours un reportage
sur didier drogba en ait have you been
des mains
on a les matchs en photo parce qu'on n'a
plus un euro
car on dépense tout pour garder lizarazu
bonjour à tous c'est l'émission préférée
de ceux qui mettent des pulls à leurs
perroquets
les chiens les missions sont capables de
jongler
le tien vomi sur le câble est leur chat
sont mignot est super sympa les tiens
déchire t'aidera
bonjour à tous un pur sang arabe a pris
ses aises l'émission préférée de tous
les experts comptables on va parler de
l'homme qui a fait fortune en inventant
des sets de table
on n'a pas le temps de chanter parce que
le générique est trop court on est
dimanche
c'est capital bonsoir à tous jean-luc
fait rigoler comme jean midi et ce raid
articulaires géraldine utilise des mots
que mokhtar ne comprends pas trop c'est
cyril l'appelle mon bébé c'est qu'il se
rappelle pas du nom de l'invité faudra
dire à françois viaud qui reviennent
chercher sa clio dans quelques amis fait
sa chronique de l'ormeau lice détruites
[Applaudissements]
radio
ils sont prêts
les foires comme celui là
c'est parfait